I'm ready when you are all right
um I grew up in a really tiny town in
White Salmon Washington
um it's got a population of probably
like 1200 people if it hasn't gone up
since I left
um I was raised by a single mom and have
two older brothers
and
um once I was about 20 years old I
started thinking about joining the
military
um I left for Fort Sill in 2013 and did
my basic training there and it was
awesome
I loved every part of it and then AIT I
trained to be an Intel analyst and then
I spent eight years doing that in
Colorado
and once I got out then I went to Hawaii
to spend some time with my Dad he's
getting hospice care and my brother's
also over there and his new baby
so that's kind of an overview but
um
to fill some gaps
our mom was a very sick individual a
very
combative really aggressive a lot of
anger problems and then in her 40s she
was diagnosed with like dementia early
dementia and so that made more sense but
um basically my childhood was like
drastically different than my brothers
they're five and six years older than me
all three of us have different dads and
my oldest brother and I
um we had no relationship with our
biological fathers I was about nine
years old when I decided to try to find
mine in a phone book and call him up and
I was able to get a hold of him and um
throughout my childhood because of what
my mom had put us through I had this
fantasy that my biological father would
find out that I existed when I was nine
and then maybe come and rescue me from
that
um and then I met him and he was a total
[__] he made me feel really stupid
um he was like commenting on my eye
color and I'm like nine so I don't know
anything about anything and he said that
my eyes were Hazel and I said I think
they're like kind of a greenish color
and he was like yeah that's like Hazel
and that's all that sticks out from my
relationship or interaction with him
um
and the reason why I was so fixated on
finding him and being rescued by him is
because uh being that I was much younger
than my brothers
and my mom herself had grown up in like
foster care because her mom had her when
she was 15 and then she was raised by
her grandma for a little bit and then
her grandma passed away when my mom was
16 and then she decided to run away then
she ended up in juvie for that and then
eventually she found a good foster mom
who ended up being like a grandma to me
and my brothers and being really good to
us we went to Christmas at her house
every year and got the full like Grandma
experience she's a great cook and like
so loving
um super Christian so that kind of
changed like my perception of different
things growing up
um
but to get a little bit deeper into some
of my mom's issues with me
uh I feel as though even though I'll
never know because she didn't talk to me
about it
um I feel like something pretty terrible
must have been happening to her when she
was a kid and going through foster care
maybe or in juvie or out on the streets
and it seems like it took such a toll
that instead of her viewing me as like
her daughter and her child
it seems like she saw me as like a
reflection of herself and just kind of
like poured all that shame and hatred
into me
um and that looked a lot like
deliberately leaving me with people who
were gonna do
bad things to me
um
some of like the earliest memories that
I have are
sorry
okay take your time
do you look like your mom no not at all
I'm glad
but uh
um some of my earliest memories of some
of the things that happened to me with a
lot of people throughout my childhood
was
um
like smells and feelings and sights of
like blood like not full memories right
but there will be like little things
that trigger like a little bit of a like
a shred of a memory but um
as I got older it became a lot more
clear to me like
what I was going to be expected to do
with these people
and as I became more aware of it I would
push back because there's
certain people
um certain like
uh I don't know how to describe them
like
pedophiles that
are good at making it seem like a treat
they're good at like giving money or
candy or food or clothes or toys and
like making you excited to be there and
then shifting it
and then some people are just like
like awful right off the get-go
um and it led to a lot of confusion of
like why am I being left here like
because my understanding is like they're
babysitters or their friends of mom or
like there's she trusts me with these
people
and uh
sorry let me just collect my thoughts so
as I got older and more aware and more
experienced with certain people because
I'd see the same people again and again
and as I got older that was an indicator
to me that she was like this was a
choice
that she was making to take me to these
people
um
so as that realization started to set in
as I got older and this is before I met
my dad so between like birth and nine
um I would push back a little bit more
and threaten to run away say I don't
want to go I don't want to like don't
leave me here I don't want to stay here
and each time that would happen I'd be
stuck in my room and she'd like
literally nailed the Windows shut
and then lock my door and uh
and leave me like for a long time like
not long and like the grand scope of
things but like a day or two as a kid
just being locked in a box like no
bathroom or anything like that
that uh
[Applause]
it really uh
changed I think what I could have been
growing up and um
so yeah that really fed into this desire
for somebody to come and scoop me up and
take me away from it that being said
though as clear as I made it that I
hated certain things
certain ones weren't that bad right so
that's where it kind of goes from like
um like I don't want to do this into
shame because
it started to feel like with certain
people it wasn't being done to me it was
something I was doing and I was so
afraid that people were gonna find out
and uh
I didn't it's like so hard to explain
like a child's uh like mindset about
things like this
because
as a kid like I wasn't thinking like oh
people are gonna call me like a [__] and
think I'm promiscuous as a child I'm
thinking I don't know what this is but
it feels gross it feels wrong I know at
least my friends like don't want to be
naked around other people and so like
given that comparison
um
it just felt like I was like really
[__] up and being gross
and it was my choice and uh
that like over time once these things
stopped
uh that just kind of became like my
understanding of how to interact with
men
um so around the age of 14
is beginning to taper off
and I got my first period that year
and my mom actually
um purchased like cemetery plots at Lyle
cemeteries like 20 minutes away from my
hometown and she like walked me up into
the cemetery and showed me my plot and
said like
this is where you're gonna be because
you're done I'm done like she was I
think she was trying to get across the
like my my purpose my what I was meant
to do for her I didn't have that job
anymore because
I'm not like
right for it anymore I felt you're too
old exactly I felt like I was being like
like fired like terminated basically
this is rural Washington yeah very rural
rural and that uh that really feeds into
it too because
in a town that small
everyone knows everyone perception is
reality and my mom was perceived as this
like beacon in the community she had a
daycare when I was a kid and then around
the time that I went to middle school
she finished up her master's degree in
like sociology or something and she got
a job with the Head Start in town the
only Head Start in town as like the
center coordinator so kind of like a
principal
and so like everyone in the community
especially in our church just thought
she was like the best thing ever and I
could never relate to that because she
was like such a [__] monster at home
like she was psychotic like he was doing
this for money
I don't know what it was for because we
really struggled with money like I know
I talk about her having a master's
degree but like the way I described my
home growing up is it's literally a
single wide trailer they took half of
the trailer off and built onto it to
turn it into a house so like we had like
this like Shack of a house with a
trailer hitch still attached did she
have a drug problem no
not that I know of and then it was just
last year in Hawaii with our dad who's
getting hospice care
because he's on like such heavy
medications he had like he had substance
abuse issues so now he's got cancer and
they're trying to treat pain and he's
got such a like high threshold for pain
medications and things like that so in
that delirium he's admitted a few things
that I didn't know about my mom like
that they dealt cocaine before the boys
were born that would have been in like
the early to mid 80s
but after that my experience with her
growing up was like very Christian no
drinking except maybe a glass of wine
anytime I would cry as a kid she thought
I was on drugs she'd accused me of being
on drugs if I was breaking down because
she was being like crazy and throwing
[__] or slamming things and it was too
much
as soon as I'd start to break down she
couldn't see it for like the reaction
that it was but she treated it more like
it's just coming out of the blue and
like why are you why are you acting so
crazy you must be on something
in like again I kind of like absorbed
all of that and uh
I got really heavy into drinking after I
turned 14. but I never touched drugs
because I was so afraid of any like
weird Behavior I had being tied to that
and it helped me though because when I
did decide to enlist and go for like a
TS clearance my background check was
pristine because I'd never been busted
for anything or been on anything I was
giving them honest answers in the
interrogation but
um
so
between 14 and 16
she was done with me
and made it very clear she wanted me out
but it's not the same as living in like
a bigger city because you can't just
like walk out on the street and find a
stranger to crash with or whatever like
I said like everyone knew me everyone
knew my mom so
when I did get out of the house I had to
just like go back there
and
um so I started parting a lot when I was
14 that was like freshman year of high
school
I got my first boyfriend
um and uh
between 14 and 15 with him especially
everything that I'd kind of like piled
up when I was little started to like
cause problems with that relationship
because like
teenagers are kind of thinking similarly
like when they get into relationships
right start thinking about like sex and
things like that kissing everything
and it was like so weird for me because
I had such an aversion to him kissing me
so we put that off for almost like the
whole first year of our relationship we
didn't kiss which I know seems ironic
but then he started to like want us to
lose our virginities to each other and
it like destroyed me
because uh
I wasn't thinking about it that way like
by that age I'd come to terms with
certain things I'd heard enough about
the things that people were doing to
know like more about like what I'd been
partaking in when I was a kid and so for
me like he's thinking we're going to
lose our virginity to each other and I'm
thinking like I lost it like when I was
probably like four like
and so and it just it made me [__]
hate him so much
he was so nice to me he's like the best
high school boyfriend you could possibly
have
sorry it's so weird because I don't know
you but
um
but um
he would like take me out on nice dates
and buy me things
and uh he got his like license and he
wanted to drive me everywhere and he was
like he was like obsessed with me he was
so good to me and I was so [__] nasty
to him because I like couldn't really
I felt like I hated him so much and I
couldn't make sense of it
but I just started acting on it and uh
and at these like parties that I was
going to when I was that age
um
I would just like Get Wrecked and then
just like act like a [__] like as soon
as I was drunk I wanted to take my
clothes off and I wanted people touching
me and talking to me and taking me
places like I wanted it I felt like that
was like
what I was supposed to do
and um and like obviously he couldn't
take that like he wanted to stay
together to
and he wanted to stay friends and
everything and then I'd like give him a
hug and it's trying to turn into more
and I like couldn't handle that and uh
eventually we fully broke it off this is
like before I even turned 16.
and um shortly thereafter I had my 16th
birthday
drunk on like the floor of someone's
trailer watching fireworks on TV
and um it was about a week after that I
went to another party in town at this
place called The Grange hall it's like a
barn basically where people have like
bigger parties in town
and so I went there to see
um like friends of a friend who were
playing in a band there
and after they finished playing I went
outside to see like what's happening
afterward and there was one guy who's
like I think he was probably like 19 or
20 at the time
and I'd seen him at a few different
parties he and his girlfriend were like
known to like kind of coordinate a lot
of this stuff so I went up to him
I was like what's going on tonight
where's the party and you say oh yeah
like we're gonna go with my friend
Jeremy we're gonna drive up to Trout
Lake there's going to be a ton of people
there
and so I got in the car with those two
and his friend Jeremy and we went up to
Trout Lake which is an even smaller town
that's like 20 minutes like up into the
woods they have one gas station and like
a little like corner store
and we get to Jeremy's house and it's
just this guy and his girlfriend and
Jeremy and Jeremy on the way up there
was talking about like he just got
divorced so I'm thinking like he's like
old as [__]
and so we get up there and we're like
sitting around and kind of drinking and
I'm just thinking as time goes on I'm
like when is everyone gonna get here
like there's like nobody [__] here
this is lame and so I told the guy the
one that I knew I was like I'm just
really tired I just want to sleep and
then maybe you can like drive me back
down the hill in the morning and that
guy Jeremy was like here you can take my
room I'll sleep on the couch and so I
went and I passed out in his room and
then hours after that I wake up to him
like crawling into bed and reaching
under my shirt
and like
I didn't I just went with it right and
um but it felt [__] like it just felt
so awful because that had a little break
from that and like every interaction I'd
had after that was like fully like my
Pursuit and something that I thought
like I was into and that felt like what
I was used to which is like I'm just
here and like you're gonna do what you
need to do
and I need to just like like wait until
it's over and then we're good and it's
fine
and so that happens but at night Corey
and his girlfriend left and went back to
their house so they left me alone and
this guy Jeremy's house and he didn't
take me home for like two days
and like it just kind of like
At first I felt like really like
disgusted and like shut down because it
took me back to that
but shortly after that I started looking
around and I'm like this is like
somewhere that I can stay though and not
go back to Mom and I [__] hated my
mom at that point and she hated me she
was like so volatile all the time and
like school was like a dumpster fire for
me
every year I'd like start strong and
then I just quit turning in my work and
sleeping in class and dressing like [__]
and acting out
and so by that time I like given up on
school and so I was thinking like I'm
just gonna drop out and I'm just gonna
stay here
and so I did that and uh
after some time had gone by with this
guy Jeremy my brothers caught on to what
was happening because like I said
everyone knows everyone and people knew
Jeremy and those same people knew my
brothers and word got to my brothers
that this like 30 year old man was like
in a relationship with me and I I had
just turned 16.
and my brothers at that point in my life
it was so weird because like it felt we
never really like bonded that well
because there's such a huge age Gap in
our experiences at home were so
different and as soon as they could move
out they did which was when I was like
11 and 12.
and um so I wasn't like close with them
in that way but when they heard about
this they went and found Jeremy at work
and they like cornered him and beat him
up and I guess like well I don't want to
say something like incriminating but
they like really [__] him up
and then he stopped talking to me for a
couple days and I know this sounds weird
right but like I couldn't [__] handle
it I couldn't handle being like left by
him
like after I had like decided that
that's where I wanted to be
um I was just like so upset that I would
have to like go back
and so I would not leave him alone and
basically we had this Arrangement where
like he would come into my hometown and
then have me like hide in the back seat
of his car so he could take me back to
his house
and things went like that for a little
bit
and then
um my mom was aware of the situation
after that too and told me that I like
could not come home after that
and uh so I stayed with Jeremy and then
when I was 17 I got pregnant and
um
of the time I was trying so hard to act
like him and like emulate that age
and that like maturity level and like
life experience and stuff I was like
yeah I'm ready to start a family like
this is what I want too and so I got
pregnant and then we got engaged and we
had a son together
and um
I really really tried to like fit that
fit that mold and like be a good mom
because like I knew that even at that
age like I really wanted to be the
complete opposite of her like I spent
probably my whole adult life trying to
identify an opposition with my mom
but um I just like I felt like I was
[__] suffocating because like once I
had our son I looked at myself
differently I felt like
like more important because I'd made
somebody I was in charge of somebody
like and that made it like so much
harder to
be around Jeremy or like act like a
partner to him because I didn't see it
that way anymore I felt like I was more
like a possession to him or like someone
just kind of coexisting with him
and because like the attraction was
starting to wane then he just wait until
I fell asleep and do it then and so like
I just after I think maybe like a year
of that I couldn't do that anymore I got
a job at Big Five Sporting Goods and I
started to think like I can find a way
out of this I can like work really hard
and get my own money and get out of this
and it was actually while I was at big
five I met my recruiter's wife and was
training her there
and she started to tell me about like
the military and what it could do for my
life like school being paid for and
medical benefits and maybe even the
signing bonus depending on what kind of
job you get and if you get the Intel
Analyst job you'll have a clearance to
fall back on and this is like
embarrassing to admit now with um kind
of like the culture of everything but I
really wanted to be a cop when I was
that age and so I'd gone on a few
ride-alongs and tried to get an idea of
like what I would need to have to go and
apply for a job like that and a lot of
them had military experience but
specifically they said don't be an MP be
an Intel analyst because so many people
fall off this job after like a year
and you'll want like a clearance to fall
back on to get your foot in the door for
like high paying entry-level jobs
so
that's uh when I started to kind of like
think about starting over and like
making something out of my life and
getting away from my hometown and
getting away from Jeremy but
unfortunately what ended up happening is
as I was approaching my ship date for
basic training he like preemptively
filed for divorce and I was like not to
make excuses but I was a dumbass kid and
I asked somebody else to read the court
paperwork for me and be like what am I
about to sign can you explain to me like
what this says what is this
and they said like oh it's like nothing
is going to change everything's going to
stay the same it's there's no changes
you're just going to be divorced and I
was like [__] yeah that's exactly what I
want
and it turns out that I was like
agreeing to not have custody of our
child anymore and also agreeing that I
owed him back child support for months
and I signed it like happily willingly
signed that and uh right before I
shipped out it's finalized I get my
paperwork I give it to my recruiter so
that he can start figuring out like how
many dependents do I have what kind of
pay am I going to get when I'm at basic
training and I'm thinking like hell yeah
like I'm gonna get BAH because I have my
son as a dependent I'm gonna put a bunch
of money away I'm gonna come out with a
fat savings account for us and we can
start fresh
instead I showed up to basic training
owing back child support
and then something that a lot of people
don't realize is it takes a minute for
your pay to catch up in basic training
and so I'd only earns like one month
worth of pay before it was Christmas
block leave and our drill sergeants had
told us like
you can stay here for Christmas block
leave and just clean and get smoked the
whole time like have to do like push-ups
basically or you can buy yourself a
ticket and fly back home and go have
Christmas and like who's that lucky who
gets to do that in the midst of basic
training and so I was thinking like I
don't have [__] for money right now but
like I'm gonna use this paycheck to fly
back home and like see our son and spend
time with my brother
and uh
and I had a car leased at the time and
I've like never told anybody this
because I'm like embarrassed about it
but basically I didn't have money to
make that payment I skipped the car
payment and bought a plane ticket
instead so I could go back home
so what ended up happening is my car was
taken away right
um and then with the back child support
like my credit was destroyed
and so I graduated AIT and luckily a lot
of people got like interim clearances in
AIT because their investigations were
still going but like my clearance came
through lickety-split because there was
nothing to it and so instead of having
an interim clearance I had a full-on
like TS clearance when I graduated
which was a blessing because my credit
got ruined at the same time and that's a
huge part of maintaining your clearance
is having like good finances good credit
so that people can't use like your
financial instability is leverage over
you I think that's basically what
they're worried about
um and so once I had my job I was just
like riddled with anxiety that I was
going to lose it at any time because you
lose your clearance over [__] like this
all the time I had to take people to go
and like get flagged for having [__]
up finances
so I had that hanging over my head and
then the custody of course and in the
midst of that is sloppy and stressful as
everything was while I was at AIT I met
my second husband
and he was my age like a couple years
older than me like the most like
physically fit like normal looking guy
probably in our class and so when he
started giving me attention at AIT I was
thinking like one I didn't think I had
it like this and two like this will
really be my new life like I'll have a
spouse that's my age that I'm really
happy with and really attracted to and
then like we can be together and that
can make it even easier for me to get my
son back
but
um once I graduated and moved to
Colorado with my second husband he was
[__] crazy too which it took me a
long time to realize that you kind of
repeat those patterns throughout your
life until you deal with it
um again just really volatile serious
anger issues and then like a ton of
cheating throughout like right off the
bat
and uh when I had to go back home after
AIT to get my things and moved on to
Colorado and in that time I met up with
my like childhood best friend
and I told her a little bit about like
what had already happened and she was
like you need to get this annulled like
this is not a good guy this is [__] up
like you need to get out of this and
then just like come back home and I was
like that's not an option anymore like I
have to go to Colorado I have to be
married I'm not going to leave this
person this is my chance like no matter
how like [__] up and crazy he's acting
I really wanted my life to look better
and like different and have a chance to
turn this around I still felt like I
could undo the damage that had been done
but it just got like
too much to handle like we're calling
the cops on each other like he would
break [__] and hurt me and I would call
the cops and then he'd go and call the
cops to make it look like he hadn't done
anything and it was such
a mess there too
um
that like just a couple years after that
I flew back home for a little bit
and stayed with Gaby again
and in that time though I went back home
and I was like starting from scratch or
trying to
and uh I I got like all of my military
[__] moved up to Washington I got like
everything done that I needed to have
done and then I even started working
like side jobs and stuff and then I was
borrowing
this couple from Church's car into like
a buy my own
and
over time though I'm like so shitty
about communication or I was that I was
like blowing baby off and not talking to
her when I was having worse days
and then Ryan was reaching out my
husband and I wanted to like I really
wanted to make that work I wanted to go
back to that and I had hope that maybe
like if he got like anger management or
something like he said he did maybe it
would be like totally different if I
just gave it another shot and like as
I'm blowing Gaby off she's being hurt by
that because she worked so hard to get
me set up there and take care of me and
give me a soft place to land and then I
just wasn't even talking to her
um and so she got pissed and she texted
me while I was at work one day and she
was like
um these people my my friends from
church they want their car back if you
don't give it back today they're going
to report it stolen
and
um and I no longer had a place to stay
because I was also like rooming with
another couple from church who had like
a renovated garage or whatever so in one
day and one Fell Swoop no car no place
to stay and like Ryan in my ear so for
me it was like such a clear choice I
have to just go back there at least
there I have my own apartment with my
husband we have a car I have a life
there I'm like somebody there I'm not
just this like free-floating thing back
home
surrounded by all my peers who are like
flourishing in their lives right now and
that was like the added thing I know
that seems Petty but it like
it just felt awful to work that hard to
change things and then be surrounded by
all these people that didn't have to
work that hard and their lives are
taking off and yours is tanking
and uh
so I made the choice to return to
Colorado
and it was about a year after I came
back to Colorado
that Ryan and I had our son together
um and I have him he's the light of my
life I felt a lot more ready for him and
able to take on mothering
um in the midst of all this instability
though I really came to terms with the
fact that like if I were to re-enter my
first son's life that would be such a
detriment to him because as gross as
Jeremy had to be to be a 30 year old man
pursuing a 16 year old child
he had like remarried already and to
somebody his age
and our son was like settled into life
with them and calling that lady mom at
that point
and I started to feel like
I wasn't ready for that I don't know
that I could ever like move far enough
away from my experience with his dad to
not have that effect how I treated him
or raised him I knew how my mom treated
me based on things that she'd
experienced or things that I'd feel like
she probably experienced
and I made the decision over time that
I'm not gonna pursue that I'm hoping
that he'll do what I did when I was a
kid and he'll wonder about me and want
to be rescued and maybe like find me and
reach out to me because he still lives
so close to my brother who still lives
there and that like I feel like it would
just be so easy for him to find me if he
wanted to I feel like I want to leave it
his choice to like try to search for me
rather than like try to like infiltrate
his life in that way because there's
just so much that would come along with
that so much explanation like
you know as he gets older I'm sure he
can factor in the age difference and
understand what that means but at the
age that he is now which um he's like
still a kid for sure but uh I think that
it would just be like so damaging and so
disorienting to a child at that age like
he's going to be coming up on like
puberty soon and things like that and I
feel like that would just decimate a kid
at that age
to like have their their absentee mom
like re-enter the picture and explain
why they left in the first place and
have to Grapple with the idea that like
their dad played into that somehow the
person who is raising them
so
my choice now is to leave it and raise
my other son and
um
uh while I was in the military
it got like trickier and trickier to
balance things out with my second son's
dad my second husband
and um eventually I mean I would have to
so we're dual military or we were he had
the same job as me obviously we went to
AIT together and but he worked at
division so he was like a desk jockey
and then I worked in first brigade so I
was actually doing like field training
pretty often because we're supposed to
be like the first to deploy if something
happens
so I was in the field constantly
and uh in that time he was very clearly
like not honoring our relationship and
it just making it like obvious to me
um and a big part of that that like
really uh
wasn't something that I was like willing
to deal with anymore as the thought that
like our kid was in the house when he
was like having different people
around and uh so our sun wasn't even a
year old when we divorced or we split up
and then we filed for divorce but that
court case got dropped so many times
because I wasn't around to even go to
the first hearing the initial status
conference
um
and a couple years after we divorced is
when I shipped to Afghanistan for my
first and only deployment
um
and I was very excited about that I
didn't want to leave our son but I was
so excited for the chance to have that
experience because it's like kind of a
rarity these days for like regular
military people to deploy like SF is a
totally different ball game but like
just regular like combat support Moses
that you don't really expect to like get
to deploy unless you're staying in for
like 20 years and so the fact that I had
that opportunity was so exciting to me
and again thinking about all the money
I'd saved not paying rent not paying a
car payment and just stacking like
combat pay on top of that
and it was also really nice and really
fulfilling for me because I trained so
hard on that job and then I finally
actually got to use those skills in like
real life scenarios so again I felt like
very purposeful very important and like
motivated about my future
but um about halfway through
I was working co-ops so that's current
operations ocean open source
intelligence analysis
um ISR so that's Intel surveillance and
reconnaissance uh basically you tell
like the drones where to go and what to
look for and they give you like counts
of like Personnel at different compounds
and things like that so we can decide if
we're gonna
send anything that way right
um so in the mix of all that right as
fighting season was ramping up in the
summertime
we heard over like the speakers on the
fob
um like the bass
uh that somebody was shooting at the
base and so everyone's freaking out and
thinking it's like very very serious
right because we get reporting all the
time that I'm looking at myself saying
like these are people that were
targeting this is the place that we're
targeting in the time and everything so
I'm looking at reports that back this up
as a possibility
and uh once I heard that over the
speaker and everyone's talking about it
in the jock so the joint operations
center
um it was my job to kind of brief
everyone on what was happening and then
help make a decision about what qrf was
going to do about it now
um I had like two sets of orders for
this deployment and one was from NATO
and that was advise and assist so what
people imagine we were doing in
Afghanistan like training their own
military and police and then I had a
second set of orders from 4 ID which
basically said that it was gonna
possibly be more of an offensive Mission
with some like support for like
Parliament elections but um
basically uh
when this person was shooting at the
base we called in the Afghan police to
deal with it first
but they didn't want to approach the
persons this person standing in like
really tall grass right outside the fob
near like the vehicle entry point I
think and um
it was hard to make out like
what they looked like or what their age
might be or anything like that but the
Afghan police wouldn't even approach
this person they're standing like a
field away and won't come any closer and
this person's just like unloading rounds
at the fob with a pistol granted but um
he dug down into the grass when he
noticed the Afghan police were
in the area
and when he came back up we had such
like uh blurry footage from the drones
basically that when he stood back up
everyone around me was so convinced he
had a beard right that's what we look
for too to determine is this someone
who's like a like military aged male
right and so I was like I'm thinking
like yes let's like
put this to a stop let's end this like
qrf is on the way they'll deal with it
do what you need to do
and um
so they arrived right on the other side
of the fence and they got their 50 cal
ready we waited and then they shot the
guy down and it was like completely
excessive right it's a 50 cal for like a
human being that's not that far away I
don't know if you've ever seen a 50 cal
firing but it's like insane
and um and then after that all happened
and the guy was clearly like dead in the
fields
um I I had to like keep eyes on this
person right so I'm like watching the
footage of this person like convulsing
on the ground eventually they stop and
he was left there for like the whole day
and as time is going by and we're using
like different tools to get footage of
this
we looked at the peateds footage and it
turned out that this was like a little
boy who had ducked into the grass when
he saw the police coming and he tried to
kill himself he shot himself like in the
mouth but it didn't kill him so when he
stood back up he was very disoriented
and had blood like running down his
cheek and chin and neck and it looked
like a beard with like really poor
footage but once we looked at the
peateds footage which is what I used to
get clearer images to build a storyboard
which is basically like images from
start to end and explanations analysis
and any reporting that might go along
with it and like I said like I even I
had reporting talking about hakani
Network patrolling that specific Village
that was in that area
and I had to explain that um
once once we did find out that it was a
child once some people had come to like
gather the body later in the day
um
then I had to explain that hakani
Network's been going to these Villages
it's a normal thing for them to like
give weapons to kids and send them
outside of the fob because it will set
off this type of chain of events and
it's easy to like build propaganda off
of that
and say like hey look they're just like
killing the kids in the village for no
good reason like don't trust them don't
talk to them because that's what we
count on right we count on people all
around the fob in these villages to give
us like reporting about threats and
things coming down the line right so
that's like a great way to get people to
not want to talk to you if they think
you're a monster that just kills kids
for no reason and so it worked out
exactly the way that I think that they
wanted it to
um but once that happened and I had to
like watch that whole thing play out
realized that it was a kid and then used
images of this dead kid just laying out
and stiffening in the Sun Well nobody's
coming to collect his body and that's uh
that's like that's the hardest part for
me is that like nobody was coming to
collect him up
and
um I don't like it felt different if it
had been a man I was like [__] it like
he's doing some bad [__] like whatever
he can lay out there and then I found
out that he was like 12 years old and I
was like where are his parents why
didn't they come and get him he's like
turning yellow and [__] like when
they they put him in the back of a truck
to take him away and they just like
picked him up and like tossed him down
in the back of the truck and drove off
and I could just see his like stiff body
like rattling the back of the truck and
I couldn't [__] believe it because I
was like
it just like like that's a kid like and
I think that I had spent enough time in
a different kind of life and far away
from my mom and not talking to her to be
so far away from my experience of like
feeling and I know there's no comparison
right but I felt like so far away from
being a kid that wasn't like cared about
I felt like that could have happened to
me when I was a kid and nobody would
have really noticed that's how I felt
when I was a child and that got kind of
reactivated when I watched this
um
happened with this kid in Afghanistan
and so that being said when I came back
home from that I felt so differently
and uh so like careless like I felt like
very indifferent like I didn't give a
[__] about my job anymore and I didn't
like the people I was around and I just
didn't see the point of any of it and
you've like you can't be that way and
like do your job in the military right
and um
and then I started having like sleep
issues and panic attacks and like anger
issues and uh finally I took myself to
behavioral health
and I found a psychiatrist there and
just started telling him like I don't I
can't function like I want to be dead so
bad I want to be gone so bad like
it's so uncomfortable to just exists
because you know I worked so hard to get
away from one thing and then it's on to
the next thing I worked so hard to get
away from that thing and fix it and then
it's on to the next thing
and then and then I'm like back through
the [__] with my second husband and I've
got to work hard and get through that
[__] and then deployment again it felt
like a huge opportunity and something
that was really gonna like 180 things
for me but um it just seemed to dig me
deeper and deeper and keep pushing me
back
so um
so I started talking to the psychiatrist
and he explained to me it's like you we
can manage this we can get you on
medications you can do this or you can
be medically discharged because you have
PTSD that will discharge you for that
and so I just took him up on that and uh
I was like let me let me get the [__]
out of here because I can't do this
anymore as badly as I wanted this as
badly as I wanted to like complete a
career and like do good and be worth
something and make all this money
um I just like I couldn't [__] do it
and I didn't care anymore and it started
to become like really hard to like find
a way to put anything into my son right
because that was just like you know
he's a child that I love him so much I
would never do anything bad to my son
right but like it was it that you know
mothering should come fairly naturally
right and I felt like I had to like
force myself to take care of him and
like that was making me hate myself even
more because uh I was like this isn't
coming naturally and and it's like so
much work to just give him the bare
minimum and he deserves so much more
than that and uh
so once I got out
um it was crazy as I was getting out
covet hit
and uh it was actually I was at a
voluntary 30-day inpatient program
called strong hope in Utah some
excellent program
um
but while I was there and getting a lot
of help from my problems and getting on
antidepressants and everything
we started seeing like news on the TV
and our little like Clinic area talking
about this new virus from you know and
uh and everyone's freaking out and
thinking like what is this should we
take it seriously and lo and behold I
get back from this 30-day program and
like all hell is breaking loose there's
like the quarantines and everything like
mass panic and like everyone
misunderstanding what's going on and
having no trust and business is shutting
down and my plan had been like okay I
I'm gonna tackle these like mental
issues that I'm having right now and
then I'm gonna go back to school I'm
gonna finish school there's still a
chance right
and uh I get enrolled in school and with
covid happening all the classes change
to like an online format and I was going
to a community college at the time and
their online format was garbage it was
so [__] hard and so I ended up just
giving up on that
and uh just kind of like coasting along
for a little bit
until
um
until uh
my second husband he had been in Korea
for like a little over a year and he was
anticipating coming back to the states
he was supposed to finish out his
contract there get out of the military
and come back to Colorado to help me
co-parent so we could do 50 50.
and he met a woman over there and they
got serious very quickly and he decided
to move to California with her instead
of coming back to Colorado
and when that happened I was like I
don't know what the [__] I'm doing here
like I want to go I want to go back to
Washington or somewhere and I knew that
my oldest brother was on the big island
in Hawaii we spent some time there when
I was little
and so I reached out to him and he had
just had a baby he was telling me that
our dad was over there getting hospice
care
and I decided that like I just wanted to
be close to like the little bit of
family that I like felt good about and
wanted to be close to I wanted my son to
like get that experience too because
he'd never met any of my family
um
and it was there that like kind of uh
the type of person that I had tried so
hard to be in my adult life I stopped
caring about it and I wanted to do
something easy and so with covid with
you know everything else that's
happening right now and only fans being
such a huge thing I decided to get into
that a little bit for easy money somehow
I had like I mean not like a lot of
people following me on social media and
stuff but enough that like immediately I
was raking in like so much money doing
that and I started to feel like you know
I don't really give a [__] like what
this looks like to anybody anymore I
just want to like make my money and like
and just enjoy my life for once I was in
Hawaii and making easy money I had like
I had to spend 10 minutes a day to make
like 30 Grand in a month you know like
it was a no brainer for me for a long
time but um
I also like started to feel kind of
burned out on just doing the same [__]
all the time and having to talk to these
people because that's another part of
that you don't get to just like post
pictures and videos you need to like
respond to people and send out more [__]
for them to pay for
and I just didn't want to keep talking
to these people because they've got all
these expectations and uh and I was I
don't I don't care about those people
you know like I was like just look at me
that's it and then give me your money
and that's all I want like but um
one person that was uh subscribed to my
only fans found after he found my only
fans he found my Instagram
and uh
he messaged me a few times saying like
I'm on the big island too can I like
take you out to coffee can I take you to
dinner whatever and I'm thinking like
this another person that thinks I'm
gonna be like a prostitute and they can
meet up for a date and then like pay and
have me for like the whole night or
whatever and I don't want to deal with
that [__]
and so I put it off and put it off and
then eventually he like started saying
some like genuinely nice things to me
like hey like it seems like you're not
having a very good day are you doing
okay or like I'd post something about
like how I was feeling or whatever and
be like really nice and supportive about
it so eventually I was just like yeah
like let's go get coffee like my
favorite place and in my mind I'm
thinking like this guy's gonna be weird
as hell but I'm gonna have my coffee and
dip
but um he ended up being great and
that's my boyfriend now
um and he's got like an awesome job in
Virginia and so my son and I after a
while of course
um but not long enough by most people's
standards uh we ended up moving with him
to Virginia he had to leave and it was
um kind of this decision of like if he
leaves and we stay then that's it and I
felt like
he was so different than like anything
I'd experienced before
um even though it's not not the most
kosher way to meet somebody like it felt
so like good and so like
not necessarily safe but very
comfortable right away and that was
something that I like was not used to
experiencing my life like feeling
genuine care and support and like
consideration about things that were
important to me and like he took a
little bit of my background information
and it seemed like he took it upon
himself to kind of like help me figure
myself out and get better
and um and so that's where we're at now
we're in Virginia and I'm like
much happier much more stable
um I'm sure I'm still going to need
years of therapy like effective therapy
to really work through this stuff but
I'm like
feeling more optimistic about my future
I'm more sure of it than I have in a
very long time because finally I feel
like all these things that I've really
struggled with and been hurt by I've
like turned into tools for me and
experience that I can look back on to
like level myself out because
when so many like intense things have
happened
you start to feel like there's just it's
always going to happen you're always on
like high alert for the next [__] that's
going to fall apart as good as
everything might look
and that's obviously taken a toll on us
a few times but another thing that stuck
out to me is like he's so like gentle
about it and understanding about like
why I'm acting the way I'm acting and he
like really wants to learn about like
why certain things that would be so
normal to other people like really
affect me and send me spiraling and it's
like it's so cool to have someone like
passionate about learning about another
person
so
um and like my son is doing amazing uh
his dad's parents live like 20 minutes
away from us so now he gets to see his
like really wholesome put together
grandparents all the time it's obviously
had like such a great influence on him
and um it seems like things might really
turn around for us now and I feel like
so
driven now
um and I just feel like it's I feel like
it's important for like someone who's in
the midst of a lot of [__] that might be
similar to what I felt I feel like it's
important for them to see that that's
not the end state that pit is not the
end state in like healing is not linear
and like character development is not
linear you can be like a great person
for months and be a [__] person next
Second and that also doesn't have to be
the end state so as like cheesy as it
may seem like I just I feel like it's
important for people to see that you can
no matter what the circumstances are of
course I don't know what everyone's been
through but like you can dig yourself
out of it if you want it badly enough if
you want to be you have to want to be a
good person not just like be successful
and Achieve what you want but like I
really want to be like a good person and
and you know as badly as you want it
sometimes you can be like really [__]
up still and so it's like
uh yeah I just I feel like that's that's
pretty much it
it's one hell of a story it was a lot
you've been through so much it's nice to
see you getting some
good luck finally yeah yeah I feel very
very lucky and plus
um my boyfriend's mom has like she like
has me call her on me uh their Pakistani
and so that means like Mom and so like
she texts me all the time to see how I'm
doing and we have like dinners at her
house and like when when it was Eid she
like dressed me up and like it it
is feels wildly uncomfortable in the
moment with things like that that are
like so foreign but um after the fact
like it's pretty amazing to like have a
chance at that
um and so yeah I'm like very fortunate
and very thankful I know not everyone is
gonna like luck out the way that I have
but yeah it's worked out for us for sure
that's great
all right thank you so much Victoria
thank you thank you very much